hello and welcome to massively fine in
this video we are going to discuss about
the effects of exercise on immunity we
will discuss how moderate exercise has
beneficial effects on the immune
function and then we will talk about why
prolong and sternness exercise is not
good for your immune system and in the
end we will also discuss some key five
daily lifestyle changes that you can do
from tomorrow that will boost your
immunity and help you fight infections
and diseases so make sure to wall the
video till the end and let's begin
physical exercise has numerous effects
on the human body including the immune
system which was quoted by Matthew at
our in the study they did to check the
effects of exercise on immunity it is
well known that mild to moderate
exercise helps to boost the overall
immune system and activity of key white
blood cells although exercising analogy
is considered a relatively new area of
scientific discovery when 90% of papers
being published after 1990 some of the
earlier studies were published well over
a century ago for example in 1902
larabee provided evidence that changes
in white blood cell differential counts
in boston marathon runners parallel
those that are seen in certain disease
conditions you also observed that the
exertion had gone far beyond the
physiological limits and our results
certainly show that where this is the
case we make it a considerable
leukocytosis of an inflammatory type
which basically meant that prolonged
strenuous running in marathon runners
leads to a decreased function of white
blood cells over the last four decades
many studies have investigated how
exercise affects the immune system it is
widely agreed that regular moderate
intensity exercise is beneficial for
your immunity but a view is held by some
that more sternness exercise can
suppress the immune system leading to an
open window of heightened infection risk
in the ours and days following the
exercise which basically means that you
may become prone to viral flu and other
respiratory illnesses after heavy
sternness exercise as done by marathon
runners in a benchmark study in 2018
this open window hypothesis
was challenged by dr. Campbell and dr.
Turner they reported in a review article
that the theory was not well supported
by scientific evidence summarizing that
there is limited reliable evidence that
exercise suppresses the immunity
concluding instead that exercise is only
beneficial for the immune system they
said that in the short term exercise can
help the immune system find and deal
with pathogens and in the long term
regular exercise slow sound changes that
happen to the immune system with aging
therefore reducing the risk of
infections in a new article published
this month leading experts including dr.
Turner and dr. Campbell debated whether
the immune system can change in a
negative or positive way after exercise
and whether or not athletes get more
infections than the general population
the article concluded that infections
are more likely to be linked to
inadequate I'll psychological stress
insufficient sleep travel and most
importantly pathogen exposure a social
gathering events like marathon runners
rather than the act of exercising itself
co-author dr. John Campbell added people
should not feel that their immune system
will be suppressed by exercise placing
them at increased risk of korenev is
provided exercises carried out according
to the latest government guidelines on
social distancing regular exercise will
have a tremendous positive effect on our
health and well-being both today and for
the future so what were some key
takeaway points from this study number
one exercise improves immunity number
two exercise improves white blood cells
and increases their movement and
potential for fighting diseases number
three the data that sturdiness heavy
exercise decreases immunity is not clear
that is also a fourth point in exercise
physiology that is particularly
important at this point time the
researchers underlined the importance of
maintaining up good personal hygiene
when exercising including thoroughly
washing hands following the exercise to
give the body its best chance at firing
of infections they suggest in addition
to doing regular exercise people need to
pay attention to the amount of sleep
they get regular moderate intensity
aerobic access
such as walking running or cycling is
recommended with the aim of achieving
150 minutes per week in my personal life
I have made a poster of two very good
quotes that I have hanged on one of my
walls these read move more and something
is better than nothing such things keep
me motivated to do exercise at least
five days a week with a mix of cardio
and weight training
don't ignore exercise it's a powerful
medicine for our heart and arteries it
strengthens your cardiovascular system
allowing your heart to pump more blood
with less effort
it makes your tissues more sensitive to
insulin which means cells throughout
your body more easily absorb and burn
blood sugar for energy
it helps will lower your levels of
triglycerides tiny packages of fat that
float around in the bloodstream exercise
also helps to decrease inflammation and
prevent blood clotting which can lead to
stroke heart attack and other problems
finally exercise creates physiological
changes in the brain that lead to an
increased sense of well-being confidence
and an improved mood so now let's
discuss about the top 5 lifestyle
changes that you can start practicing
from tomorrow that will help you to
boost your immunity and fight off
infections number one is adequate sleep
adequate sleep is one of the most
important aspects of having a good
functioning immune system create a good
sleep hygiene ritual and I am sure there
are hundreds of other you videos on
YouTube that will help you in this
regard number two is taking small Vox
maybe 10 to 15-minute walks in your
workspace or your home number three is
to minimize stress in your life do
meditation yoga good social relations
etc that will help you to minimize
stress in your life number four is
hydrate hydrate hydrate water plays many
important roles in your body including
your immune system number five and the
last one is that there is no shortage of
supplements claiming that they can
stimulate your immune system but be wary
of these promises the one that has been
trusted since ages is only vitamin C and
500 milligrams of vitamin C a day is
adequate for a properly functioning
immune system so guys thank you so much
for watching this video if you liked
this video you can support our channel
by clicking the join button below and
getting awesome benefits in return also
you can support our community at
patreon.com and get awesome benefits in
return thank you so much for watching